alors voilà on est une bande de voleurs
quand on joue à ça
on est amené à se faire des ennemis
et il arrive parfois que nos ennemis
reviennent pour se venger
on
pour tout dire
on a été qu'il fallait pas à voler ce
qu'il fallait pas
on pensait pas libéré la plus grande
force maléfique que le monde ait connu
mais on va arranger ça d'accord et
comment on va faire
on en discute autour d'un verre beth
young
pour avoir une chance de gagner on aura
besoin de forces tu va assurer un long
billet si on compte sur toi
on aura aussi besoin de courage de magie
et de toi
c'est quoi déjà ce truc une ourse ebooks
martin
bon mais garde
le mal règne ici
je suis contente qu'il soit avec nous
cet homme est dangereux
mais quoi qu'il arrive
on sera prêt
et c'est quoi exactement tall
planificateur c'est moi qui fait les
plans tu l'as déjà fait le plein si le
plan qui était prévu foire je refais un
plan donc tu fais des plaintifs arnon et
il joue aussi du luth c'est pas le sujet
[Musique]
ans
moi
[Musique]
sasuke la couleur
[Applaudissements]
milton scolarité
comme on
n'est pas
[Musique]
d'accord
asenjo l'aude au bac 3
et l'espoir
acheter
[Musique]
on a besoin était pour bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
louis
maman c'est quoi ça
il nous faut d'autres et ça
ça nous fera du boulot en plus et nous
on ne sait pas gérer la vente en ligne
vraiment vintage par téléphone non
comment tu fais pour parler à tes amis
mon ami c'est ma mère
vous
qui êtes vous
néanmoins pour le gazole il travaille
son game le drame au moins un autre côté
le combat non sortez de chez moi que tu
te tadegnon mayotte pour le tandem et
aqua dans la valise
qu'est-ce qui a fait que je te jure ça
m'inquiète je dis que j'allais bien
c'est qui cette femme on sait pas quoi
on ne lui restait plus que
je me souviens je les entends décrié
tout le temps je n'avais pas envie tu la
connaissent
et bien certains coréens pensent que les
difficultés de la vie sans causés par
les esprits tourmentés de leurs ancêtres
[Musique]
alors c'est ça que tu veux tu peux
maintenant droit où reposer en paix
j'arrive
tout
savoir sur quoi d'autre tu m'as menti
ce
que j'ai fait je lui ai fait pour toi ça
suffit je m'en fais
tu vas aller nulle part
il est ici
chikhi
où les gens me voient comme une berceuse
en barbares
fut le plus brutal messieurs et le plus
impitoyable champion qu'il est temps y'a
personne comme moi avec la personne qui
peut égaler mon stylo en jalles j'ai
apprécié ma gardien finira bien trop
féroce je pouffe aux gamins j'arrache
des coeurs je suis vraiment ça
je t'ai donné la vie
sur la pente savonneuse d'acoz qui va
finir en taule
[Musique]
alors prépare toi
amérique
mais c'est trop mal famés ça a été ma
chance l'espoir de mon sens
et mohamed ali maintenant je vais
devenir le plus jeune champion du monde
de l'histoire
ce soit le boxeur le plus méchant que la
terre ait jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'as pas envie d'évoluer
admirez autant qu'ils vont te crade
vaut mieux que tu continues à gagner
tu vas perdre un combat ce mec là tu
voudras coup de pied au cul je te parle
de postérité
ils ont gravé dans le marbre polygamique
[Musique]
il peut soit attribué du ca près
n'importe quoi du baril
sortir plus
mais à la minute où tu prend trop de
place et surtout
je sois jamais
mais soit
si j'étais pas un chèque qui s'intéresse
[Musique]
kim non quand je suis devant vous
alexandre c'est la surprise et en vrai
bon bah c'est tellement jubilatoire de
la revoir dans la saison 2 ans une vraie
folle prête à tout donc d'autant plus
prête à tout pour gagner mais pour
gagner pour marc
tu te ridiculise devant tout le monde tu
me fous la route dans la saison 2 voilà
encore plus folles sont le premier qui
bouge sera éliminé éliminé du jeu et moi
je vous plains pas elle peut le faire
avec ça je vais te dire un truc
sur
wii c'est que tout pour marc les gogos
qui était assez drôle c'est que je je
porte marque sur des épaules havrais qui
fait beau d'un peu plus de 80 kg et mais
pour elle tout c'est tout à fait normal
c'est elle qui veut porte sur son dos
est toujours en course tout le trajet
il faut treize ans c'est assez hilarant
magie batterie là tout est romancé crawl
ans et roland gibert pied
la première saison quand on quand on va
tourner je me souviens qu'une fois
jonathan m'a dit
il faut que tu me son appel mois
peut-être pour rien dire je ne sais pas
il faut qu'on chypre ou un truc et c'est
là que ça a commencé mais c'était pas
forcément les cris
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'était génial la deuxième saison
il y avait un truc hockey se dire
alexandra faut pas que je retarde la
même chose marc
semoussac avec le personnage de marc je
peux m jonathan cohen sur mes ongles vu
que ça fait bien moi qu'on a commencé le
tournage il ya il ya déjà des doigts où
il ait pu et donc je me parla je parle à
mes dix marques et en fait j'ai
l'impression que marc en train de mourir
donc je pleure et voilà c'est du coup on
peut faire des scènes un peu comme ça
si génial je ne boude pas mon plaisir
quoi
un petit je me suis racheté en rater les
nouvelles à mes yeux des blues city
puisque alexandra n'est pas censé être
la barre des banques c'est comme si
c'était marco quand marc à alexandra
seront séparés se voit peut-être à
travers d'autres gens et donc je serai
confessions je suis mal quand john t ça
tombe mal parce que marcos et pas marque
pour ton coach va te [ __ ] donc eu vent
jonathan marc de maar qu on n'a pas
encore tourné le début de la flamme de
booba le clip du rap je veux que tu
m'appartiens jamais je te partir très
tôt ma part qu on parle de marco et puis
me voilà cherchent-elles acteurs et je
ne
il faut que ce soit toi qui le joue
ennemie c'est fou parce qu'on va en
parler ce matin
et je sais pas bref ne fait pas pour sa
part depuis cinq minutes
elle part avec moscou tu m'a aimée comme
eux comme personne ne va jamais aimé
mais voilà l'amour bain et massa se
commande pas bon mais elle par un bug
marque mais bon mais alexandra le sera
elle partira jamais vraiment qu'est ce
que tu accepterais que j'allais vivre
cet amour par coup ben oui bien sûr
vraiment
il
salue alexandra
à l'est pas
[Musique]
respirez moi ce bonheur les gars le week
end promet d'être encore plus
intéressant
c'est que l'onu à ces noms peut-être que
tu pourrais fermer ta gueule est
doucement cowboys
avec les marques sur ton visage et
impôts sous ses ongles on va pas [ __ ]
notre vie en l'air pour ça parce que tu
veux pas d'après toile
ses cris elle a filmé allons-y voilà des
noms
elles ont fait
venir de chercher salle pétards tandis
que jeudi
c'est toi en dessous kelly mais tout ce
qu'on veut c'est ta caméra
j'ai pourtant été gentil
mais y'en a marre tu me casses les
couilles maintenant
si tu préfères que ça se passe mal
n'oublie pas que j'ai d'abord été jordi
allez debout kerry
et
regarde ça jeff
qu'est ce que ça fait au mexique
un sarcophage égyptien
gênantes ou pas
est-ce que ça va très bien j'ai vraiment
aucun risque
tu es viré
elle revient
pour à la case départ meta est mauvais
sens sur la paire avec de nouveaux amis
amon
ramona non il y à des pauses à respecter
pour de nouvelles aventures
quelle équipe de choc qu'est ce que tu
as fait à mona lisa je les corriger
oh non moi quand je suis nerveuse et les
gares a
salué par des mots mais
[Musique]
alors là bravo c'est la momie la plus
riquiqui que j'ai jamais
ah ah
tu es maudit ce genre de sortie bien
faire maintenant s'il n'est pas de
risque
pat explorateurs et la table d'émeraude
bah c'est super cool au cinéma le 24
août août attendions depuis longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces séances sont obligatoires pour tout
le monde ça
ma mère souffrait de dépression a nice
je peux entrer
même si je n'étais qu'une enfant je
savais que c'était amie ouvre la porte
ils doublaient plus que ça
allait ma mère disait qu'elle entendait
une voix dans sa tête
et que cette voie ne la voulez pas elle
elle me voulez moi
la citadelle est tombé une fumée noire
masquer le soleil certains d'entre vous
le savent déjà nous avons une femme qui
vient étudier dans cette classe
seulement en tant qu'observatrice
descendons dans les entrailles de
l'enfer si vous le voulez bien
il y a plus de possession signalé de nos
jours que dans toutes les autres époques
de l'histoire nous devons combattre pour
sauver chaque art
[Musique]
défendue dans le combat contre les
esprits de la malveillance
je pense que le démon qui tourmentait
nathalie et celui qui possédait ma mère
sont en fait le même
j'aimerais enseigner sera le minimum
requis pour se protéger elle même et les
autres
la relation qu'elle a
et très personnelle
nous attendions depuis longtemps
[Musique]
tamer une très belle voix
ya quelqu'un
soyez prudentes maintenant que vous
connaissez le diable
le diable vous connaît aussi
[Musique]
vous allez voir des giroflées des
murailles une fleur comme vous n'en avez
jamais vus
oui n'était pas du tout sur la bonne
route je le cherche parce que tu m'as
trouvé
et comme message du perron de la défense
civile des états unis d'amérique
si moche que sa
peine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis le héros par les héros mais
chez vous
[Musique]
il faut qu'on trouve des armes si on y
passe par ta faute je vais t'en vouloir
à mort qu'est-ce que tu suggères jeudi
qu'il pourrait s'attirer d'un côté du
bâtiment et nous parler de votre
je suis un magicien niveau 20 à donjons
et dragons qui nous protègera
[Musique]
vous autres les asociaux pourquoi vous
kiffez les zombies on n'est pas dans une
[ __ ] de bd les gars ojjeh
tu sais combien elles m'ont coûté
est-ce qu'il est mort évidemment qu'il
est mort ryan il vient de tomber ce fait
une fois
qu'il nous faut c'est du père
t'es sérieux là
la sauce
[Musique]
j'avais l'air d'une idiata plutôt d'une
bagdad
watcha watch
[Musique]
m
marinov
[Musique]
qui ça
je
pour howard preuves techniques
batta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
vous êtes soumis aux chambres
marquer c'est tout
e
ça
cette mairie
nguema
ok
to life
à noter
[Musique]
bach
ballmer
mais j'attends c'est dangereux ici
mais tu devineras jamais ce que j'ai
trouvé qu'est ce que ces migraines
on se ressemble tellement toi et moi
j'espère
car on refuse de laisser ce monde nous
écraser
et ne crois pas tu puisse changer
l'ordre des choses je sais faire des
choses
j'ai tout appris cela
pour la citadelle nous sommes de la
vermine
la citadelle veut tout contrôler ils ne
verront pas leurs portes ils veulent
garder pour eux toutes les ressources
mais à cause d'eux ici on n'a plus rien
je dois trouver la clé pour débloquer
les graines les rendre fertile et mettre
fin à la famine pour toujours
un ring glider
[Musique]
écrasés
je m'appelle camélia
fait ce père elle n'est pas notre
problème mais elle vient de la citadelle
elle nous y conduira en route
les pèlerins les vagabonds les bandits
[Musique]
ne te fie à personne
la citadelle ne te laissera pas faire
ils m'arrêteront pas
[Musique]
c'est une fleur que changer les choses
alors moi aussi
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'habitude d'être en face
d'autant de gens qu'ils fixent du regard
et des demandes des photos
[Musique]
logique
tout le monde l'écoutait
ton père a eu un accident
artistes se trouvait dans sa maison près
de carthagène lorsqu'une fuite de gaz et
une cigarette ont provoqué une explosion
qui a causé sa mort
je te rappelle que c'était aussi mon
père il faut que je me confie à
quelqu'un parce que c'est trop pour moi
j'ai le sentiment que sa mort n'était
pas un accident j'ai besoin de savoir ce
qui s'est réellement passé disons que
dernièrement il en voulait à la terre
entière du doigt de pied qu'est ce que
tu fais ici moi c'est noir
le festival de musique créée par l
parole s'est transformé en camp bourg
demi dick retransmis à la télévision
hier
à cette première édition de lukasz
martin présente el camino del fra
je crois que c'est le moment parfait
pour lancer ta carrière
dis moi pourquoi t'as voulez mais dès
que tu vois le public veut voir les diaz
entrer en compétition
je suis venu ici pour trouver des
réponses et savoir ce qui est arrivé à
mon père piper mon frère
et j'ai découvert la musique c'est
seulement un concours tout va bien
maintenant c'est bien plus que ça
j'ai découvert et confiance en moi tout
est au losc avait atteint sur meuse
monéteau mon or ce gars là lé jeune
quitter c'est noah ce prénom il
s'entendait bien avec mon père
ça veut dire que t'étais au courant
pour être honnête je n'ai jamais trop
apprécié et au terrorisme
la question nombreuses minutes à elle va
rester dans je reste sur mes gardes
[Musique]
depuis combien de temps tu es christian
nous deux
il ne vivait que pour lui même
et d'un coup tout a basculé
je te
reste
hardy avait énormément de démons j'étais
jeune j'étais amoureuse j'étais
terrifiée et il essayait d'être meilleur
pour moi
j'arrête pas de m'entraîner dans mes
histoires déjà c'est pas juste
[Musique]
je sais pas si je peux continuer à
lutter pour sauver lui au lieu de me
sauver moi même il faut qu'on prenne nos
distances pendant un temps tu peux pas
échapper à toi même juste en allant d'un
endroit à un autre tu le sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais il la guerre des enchères pour mon
livre je ne veux pas que les gens lisent
ces choses sur moi il s'agit de nous
quel est l'intérêt de toutes les galères
qu'on a traversées si on peut pas en
faire quelque chose qui aide les gens
c'est une histoire qui parle de partons
et d'amour inconditionnel une part de
nom c'est ce genre d'histoires kafteur
raconte after
c'est mon voyage après que je t'ai
rencontrée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu vas te faire arrêter tu le sais
charbon soit que tu dois être tirée
t'étais pas là quand elle avait besoin
de toi et là tu fait qu'empirer les
choses
tu es en train d'épuiser les dernières
bribes de self control t'es même pas
idée